this brings up something that I was
curious about which is the difference
between
believing and knowing yeah yeah and
that they're still possibly a Resonance
of not believing if you need to say I
believe and that what I'm maybe hearing
is that there's some transition that
happens as they go through this process
where they just know
so is there a difference between those
two
some people do the work and when they
finish their meditation they believe
less
in their future because they actually
never overcame themselves they never
overcame that emotion right and there's
a story that's connected to that emotion
because emotions are residue chemically
of the past there's others who get up
who believe more in their future uh when
they finish the meditation and that's
the way it should because they change
their state they change their state of
being so so this is a great conversation
because I've been really exploring this
in my own in my own Journey
um belief is like pregnancy like either
you are or you're not I mean there's no
in between
uh when people have a profound
experience in their meditation
where something switches where they have
some inward moment that somehow
everything aligns the brain their body
everything lines up that kind of that
kind of alignment is an absolute
knowingness there is a knowingness that
takes place and I listened to so many of
them in the last few months say I know
I'm going to heal we just were Niagara
Falls we did a big event there and some
physician 41 years in medicine uh with a
big spinal cord tumor he had that he had
the tumor removed and they put a stint
in there and he was paralyzed for the
last 10 years and he's walking around
what he talked about more than anything
else
I he was I I was right there with him in
the audience he could he could not stop
talking about the amount of love
that he was feeling he said he had he
had never felt
that amount of love in his life now I
had to force him into saying and and
what else so how did that affect your
body oh yeah I came in a wheelchair now
I can walk around a lot better and I
have no doubt I know now I know
I'm going to heal I know it this is and
that's like that is the that is what
SEALs the belief into a complete uh
finality and so he's not trying to
believe
he he knows he knows that he knows and
there's no effort yeah exactly so so
many times people during their
meditation
have an inward event
that has such a profound uh experience
for them that they realize that inward
event produces a feeling of Love or some
connection that's trans Transcendent of
language where they where they
it the amount of Love or the amount of
Joy or the amount of bliss or ecstasy
that they feel from that moment is a
really important moment of Reckoning
because they realize it's not coming
from anybody out there it's not coming
from the relationship it's not coming
from the Wardrobe it's not coming from
their diet it's not coming from their
sports car it's not coming from Netflix
it's not coming from social media this
is a really profound feeling that they
never ever felt before that moment of
connection
somehow causes a biological upgrade in
the body and in that moment there's a
alignment to a future where they already
know and it's not like they're trying to
know
it's the side effect of some inward
event and and now they live their life
in a state of knowing and that's so much
better than doubt you know or disbelief
I went to your retreat at the end of
2020 and there's a lot of talk about 3D
versus 5D creation
and
what this sounds like to me or what
maybe I'm asking is when you get to that
point
of having that knowing or feeling
something so deeply and having that
coherence
resonance in the body are you connecting
now to the simultaneous timelines in the
quantum field of that reality actually
happening that you could feel it like
so I'm asking that and I'm asking I get
and I'm saying I would get overwhelmed
with the idea of parallel timelines and
being able to have time collapse into
everything happening simultaneously so I
just want to say that I'm it confuses my
head I can't see it clearly it doesn't
make sense to me but I trust in it so is
that kind of what's happening and I
really want to talk about creating in 5D
because I think that's where we're at
okay so I'm gonna have to unpack that a
little bit I I think this is a great
conversation okay um and for the for the
audience I think we just got to lay down
a little foundation so we don't lose
anybody right perfect so we live in a 3D
three-dimensional reality everything
that we look at an object a person
anything that's physical or material has
height and depth and width and we can
pick things up right and we can say well
that's an object and I have a body and
now that I have a body and I'm aware I'm
a Consciousness then I'm local in space
and time and and in this reality of
three-dimensional reality there's an
infinite amount of space space is
eternal space is actually accelerating
right now it's no longer expanding it's
accelerating okay so we know that space
is eternal and the way we experience
time in three-dimensional reality is we
have to go from one point of awareness
like I'm stand sitting here and if I
want to go to my garden I put my
attention on another point of awareness
that's my other point of Consciousness
now if I want to have the experience of
getting to my garden or picking a piece
of
uh fruit off my tree I have to move my
body through space and when I move from
one point of awareness to the other
point of awareness that that interval is
called time so everything in
three-dimensional reality takes time to
create you you you experience separation
I'm here and you're there and
everything's separate from me and so
our senses plug us into
three-dimensional reality think about
this if you weren't if you were lost all
your senses you weren't seeing you
weren't hearing you weren't smelling you
weren't tasting you couldn't feel with
your body you would have no experience
of three-dimensional reality and yet you
would be conscious and aware but you
would have no interaction with anything
physical or material okay that makes
sense
all right so then the way we get about
creating our future is that we say Okay
I want to have this new house I want to
have a dog I want to have a new
relationship I want to live in this
place and what the brain automatically
does based on its experience of itself
up until that point remember the brain
is a record of the past it's it's a
Memory Bank of everything you've learned
and experienced so the brain says okay
let me predict how this is going to
happen I got to take on a second job
okay I got to start saving my beans uh I
got to make better choices
um uh I may actually uh try to figure
out a way to invest better you know
you're gonna and and your brain says
okay I'm gonna have that life in two
years if I do if I if I if I get my
behaviors to match my intentions and I
keep making the same choices I'm going
to run into that experience okay so
let's think about it the same thing
occurs there's me here Joe dispenza I'm
aware that I'm local in space and time
and then where's my future way out there
my brain is forecasting it way out in
the future based on what I've done in
the past or what I know about myself in
the past okay so now I gotta go from
this point to that point and I'm
separate
from that experience so I'm gonna spend
my entire life waiting for that
experience to happen
to take away the lack or separation from
from having it so the interval between
the thought of what I want and the
experience of having it is called time
cause and effect right so then as we
said earlier when you have the
experience you get the house you know
and you pay it off and it takes 30 years
you know you're you're too old to enjoy
it you're going to sell it anyway you
know you you're everything's you know
everything's taken a lot of time yeah
and a lot of energy and it takes a lot
of time and energy to move your body
through space and time and then throw in
the hormones of stress and stress is
when you can't predict something when
you have the perception something's
going to get worse or you're going to
lose control of something in your life
you switch on that pretty primitive
system where you're going to mobilize
all your energy and it turns out that
those very chemicals actually heighten
the senses and we become more of a
materialist and we narrow our focus on
everything physical and material why
because the alert system through
adrenaline or epinephrine norepinephrine
is saying pay attention to the danger
sure so if there's something rustling in
the bushes and it's nighttime you're
going to freeze you're going to narrow
your focus
and you're going to look for something
physical or material right okay so let's
look at the human being over
Generations Untold I mean just 300 years
ago 200 years ago being a human being
wasn't easy I mean a starvation a
disease
um Predator I mean all kinds of things
were or is a strong reality so we spent
a lot of time living in survival and
living in survival over Generations
causes us to only see the material world
because that's relevant you're not gonna
really wasn't that long ago yeah and
there's a lot of things yeah and so why
would you look for energy or frequency
or the quantum or the immaterial when
everything material is vital when you're
living in survival so keep that survival
system switched on for an extended
period of time
the arousal of those hormones causes you
to feel more like your body you have
more attention on your body because if
T-Rex is chasing you you better be
thinking about your body okay and when
you're under stress and you're in
survival your attention is on the
environment why because that's where the
danger is so so now what's your
environment made of objects things
places bodies people right so it's very
material okay so now right the arousal
causes us to pay more attention to the
outer world and less attention to our
inner world than this Rush of chemicals
causes us to become very preoccupied
with trying to make that feeling of
survival and stress go away so time
becomes very relevant as well so now
your body is where you put your
attention your environment is where you
put your attention and your attention is
on time well it turns out to change is
actually to be greater than your body to
be greater than your environment and be
greater than time so if people are
spending the majority of their life with
the emergency system switched on
it's not a time to create it's not a
time to learn it's not a time to go
within it's not a time to meditate it
goes against the survival Gene that says
you will be prey it's not a time to open
your heart it's not a time to commune
it's not even a time to eat look at the
last few years yeah so people spend the
majority of their time
shutting uh let me say it another way so
then so then when a person is living in
survival and they're trying to control
and predict
and change everything that's going on in
their life every person that they know
every object or thing that they own
every place that they know or have lived
or go to and everything they've
experienced in their past they're going
to try to predict in their future so now
the arousal the stress hormones causes
the brain to fire out of order because
every person every object everything has
a different neurological Network in the
brain now the brain is firing in
coherently and when it's firing
incoherently we're incoherent at the
same time
you're sitting in the zoom meeting and
it's not T-Rex it's your co-worker and
you're actually producing the same
chemicals as if you're being chased by
T-Rex but you don't you're not running
you're not fighting okay you're not
hiding you're doing sitting there and
those those chemicals are running
through the body and the heart is
actually pumping really hard because
it's turned on
[Music]